you are walking close
welcome to another ColdFusion video to
gogo here humans are social beings
naturally most of us want to know more
about each other and what each other are
doing at a given time we also tend to
follow trends of what's socially going
on around us there's a bit of a famous
experiment that shows this to summarize
it states put one person in the middle
of the street and make him stare up at
the sky and his crazy put a group of
people in the middle of the street and
make them stare up at the sky and more
people will stop to look there must be
something interesting up there
that many people just can't be wrong
this intrinsic human nature is one of
the keys to success of what we now call
social media in this video we'll take a
fresh perspective on the origins of a
man and a website that changed the world
and then we'll take a look at some
amazing facts about Facebook and how
much they've really owned and finally
we'll finish off with Facebook's impact
on society we're going to have a lot of
fun today guys let's dive in in the mid
to late 1990s the internet was seen as
the new economy tech companies were hot
and internet companies were purifier
investors plump millions of dollars into
any company that just had a dot-com at
the end of their name even if they
didn't have any plans on making money
the year is 1998 and the first true
social media website decided to go
public they were called the globe com
the Globes value rose six hundred and
six percent on the first day that they
went public a record that still stands
today but by the next year the company
had lost 95% of its value why well it
was because of the economic calm crash
mainly but it was also due to the fact
that these guys lack discipline and a
plan after they went public they spent a
lot of money on lavish parties without
actually doing any work so the globe did
prove that social media was a popular
and intuitive idea as a pure concept but
in order to work it needed a company in
the framework with a strong sense of
direction if only someone could exploit
the natural human trait of wanting to be
connected to its full potential it could
be huge
meanwhile at this time a bright young
kid named Mark Zuckerburg had learned
programming from his father and had
already written his own software by
middle school Mark's dad had hired a
software developer to tutor the young
programmer Mark's Tudor famously stated
that mark was a prodigy and it was
actually tough to stay ahead of him in
high school mark and a friend built a
media player called synapse it used
machine learning to learn listeners
habits and recommend music that it
thought they would like synapse was such
an intriguing concept that it gained the
attention of Microsoft and other global
players but mark wasn't settling he
wanted a bigger challenge by the time
Mark graduated from high school and
entered Harvard he was a seasoned
programmer at Harvard he wrote a program
called Facemash and it was essentially a
version of hot-or-not with a voting and
ranking system Facemash went live on the
weekend and by monday harvard service
had crashed and the students couldn't
even get on the internet it was that
popular around this time the second
generation of social media was actually
starting to take off MySpace and
Friendster were gaining ground three
Harvard students Cameron and Tyler
Winklevoss and Divya Narendra had been
working on a site called Harvard
connection for a year and had recently
lost two programmers to graduation they
were looking for a new talented
programmer to continue the work after
hearing about the Facemash phenomenon it
was clear that mark was their guy mark
hopped on board but he had other ideas
although it's shrouded in controversy it
said that mark actually betrayed the
Harvard crew by working on his own site
while continuing to delay work on the
Harvard connection in the end mark took
inspiration from the social idea of
Harvard connection and the Facebook was
conceived and its name was later changed
to Facebook Mark Zuckerberg had the rare
insight to see that sharing information
could be the center of people's lives
and as we know the rest was history we
can no longer think of Facebook as just
a social network today Facebook
Incorporated is much bigger than that
studies have predicted that Facebook is
going to lose 80% of its user base by
the year 2018 so the company has no
choice they have to venture out into new
frontiers there'll be more on this later
but first here are some fun facts about
the company so how big is it on the web
is the second largest site after Google
and YouTube comes in a third as a side
point if you want to see my
documentaries on both YouTube and Google
please see the description below
Facebook currently has 1.3 billion
active users per month every 20 minutes
on Facebook
1 million links are shared 2 million
friends are requested and 3 million
messages are sent there have been 100
billion friend connections 1.3 trillion
likes and 250 billion photos since
Facebook went live here's an interesting
one originally the Facebook engineers
wanted to call the like button the
awesome button alright so how much is
Facebook worth today Facebook is worth
over two hundred billion dollars and
that's twice the value of eBay Yahoo
group on LinkedIn Netflix I a see a AOL
and Pandora combined in 2009 the Oxford
dictionary's Word of the Year was the
verb unfriend
alright so that's all nice but what
about Facebook's physical side
well let's enter the data center when
you type in facebook.com your request
goes to the open Internet
that internet lands right here and from
right here we request from one of the
Facebook servers your profile and all
the information associated with it our
data centers work and compiled all that
information and then send it back to you
right across the open Internet again and
all of that happens in milliseconds
Facebook's data center is a modern
engineering and computing marvel it's
over three football fields in area and
has twenty-one million feet of
fiber-optic cable there are thousands of
servers arriving daily and just one of
those servers is 500 terabytes of
storage that's 130 billion times more
than the first pcs the data center sees
a hundred petabytes of photos and videos
per day and for those of you wondering
that's 100 thousand gigabytes in case of
a power failure there are 14 3 megawatt
generators on standby so we know
Facebook Incorporated is now a huge
company but let's turn it up a notch
what are some of the other things that
Facebook are doing behind the scenes
let's take a look at some of the
acquisitions so many of us know that
Facebook has brought Instagram and
whatsapp but what are some other
interesting acquisitions up to February
15 2014
Facebook's acquisitions will really run
the mill but then they bought oculus VR
although I wish I knew what Facebook was
going to do with oculus there's no
information out about that yet but what
I can safely say is that it looks like
Facebook thinks this is going to be the
next big thing what do I mean by this so
initially Facebook was popular for
photos and still is one of the biggest
photo sharing sites and now you can see
that slowly starting to transition to
videos and in the future I think
Facebook thinks that virtual reality
will be the next way of sharing and
interacting with each other Facebook did
announce that there will be support for
3d spherical videos on the newsfeed page
so users can view live action virtual
reality right from their newsfeed on
March 27th 2014 Facebook bought a
company specializing in high altitude
unmanned aerial vehicles the reason for
this is internet.org welcome back
Facebook unveiling new details about its
drone that will beam the Internet back
down to earth Liz McDonald is in the
business
and his massive was yeah that's right
good morning we're good morning
everybody that is massive it's about the
size of a Boeing 737 that's according to
Facebook and basically Facebook we'll be
testing this solar-powered drone this
summer in order to being the Internet it
hopes to up to 3 billion people around
the world who do not have the Internet
the first test flights were completed in
March 27th 2015 and it does look to me
like this is actually going to go ahead
other recent acquisitions include a
fitness tracking company speech
recognition and an e-commerce company
alright so what else is there well one
of the big things that Facebook is
starting to get really keen on is
artificial intelligence they're
artificial intelligence is actually
pretty good at video recognition which
any computer scientist will tell you is
actually still quite a hard thing to
achieve right now Facebook's artificial
intelligence can tell what sport is
being played in a video without any help
just like a human would the reason
behind this is if the artificial
intelligence can tell what's going on in
a video it can recommend things that are
thinks you would like at a deeper level
so what else are Facebook playing to do
with such powerful artificial
intelligence they just state they're
going to advance the field of machine
intelligence that would give people a
better way to communicate Facebook also
boasts that they're going to have the
best artificial intelligence lab in the
world so that's kind of interesting but
hearing that may unnerve a few people
out there ok so reaching towards the end
of the video but before we continue
let's take a quick youtube ad break and
then we'll be back after this ok so
we're back
what about Facebook's impact on society
well as most of you know there's been a
recent backlash against Facebook in the
past couple of years some have called it
a hijacking of the mind while others
have called a straight-up nice ism and
yet others call it a replacement of our
natural social reality with a virtual
one a common example raised from the
anti social media movement was that it's
becoming commonplace for people to know
one another just in the most superficial
levels rather than the essence of one's
character no one ever
so close or
just patch it up anymore just a Facebook
message and that's good enough instead
of going and catching up with someone
you just talk to my chat for me
personally I don't think Facebook is all
that bad I can see Facebook is valuable
for keeping in touch with friends and
family that are far away just checking
in to see what friends are up to and
organizing events that being said
Facebook shouldn't be taken too
seriously in addition to the above
complaints there are actually some
medical concerns for a generation
growing up with a large part of their
social life in virtual form see that
blue area of the brain that's the area
that learns empathy what they found is
that those areas that learn empathy are
only active when you do nothing when you
daydream and that's something today's
teenagers don't do they're not
activating these brain areas that are
important for self-reflection and
reflecting on other people and allowing
that empathy to emerge empathy is the
capacity to understand what another
person is experiencing from the other
person's frame of reference in other
words the capacity to place oneself in
another's shoes and this is an important
part of human nature
so really it's actually healthy to
sometimes stop and reflect and also
think about others in your life all
right so let's move on from the deep
insights into some other quirky aspects
of Facebook's impact on society of
course Facebook has obviously
revolutionized digital marketing but
what else is there well there's a little
thing called ambient awareness and this
is the first time this phenomena has
been seen in human history as well let
me break it down because we're in
constant contact with our friends we
just have a new type of social awareness
where we know what everyone's doing the
majority of the time to put it another
way it's a bit like physically being
near someone and picking up those
subtleties picking up their mood or
unconsciously mirroring their body
language and somewhat having their
feelings rub off on you it really is an
interesting concept and we'll see how
this evolves in society in the future so
in conclusion the past decade has
socially been brand new territory never
before has the world been so connected
intimately Facebook has changed the way
we communicate and perceive
relationships the sheer amount of data
that is processed every day is
mind-boggling and it's amazing that this
technology enables us to stay in contact
and family from around the world cheaply
and easy and just to think it just took
one college kid
with a bit of determination and a
borrowed idea to truly change the world
so if you've got an original idea take
the steps to make it happen who knows
what it could end up being Facebook may
not be around forever but it surely has
paved the way for a new connected world
and before I leave just as a little
bonus to put what we've seen into
perspective here's a video of Mark
Zuckerberg talking about the Facebook
before it was famous this video dispels
the notion that Mark knew just how big
Facebook was going to get he really just
was a casual college kid cheers guys
thanks for watching
let's know simply what Facebook isn't
with us so I think Facebook is an online
directory for colleges yeah I mean I
think that the goal that we wanted to it
with wasn't to make an online community
but sort of like a mirror for the real
community that existed in real life and
what are you taking Facebook at this
point it expands those other schools
that you have
I mean there doesn't necessarily have to
be more you know I mean like a lot of
people are focused on taking over the
world they're doing like the biggest
thing getting the most users and I mean
I think like part of making a difference
and doing something cool is focusing
intensely like I really just want to see
everyone focus on college and create
like a really cool College directory
product that just like is very relevant
for students and like has a lot of like
information that people care about when
they're in college so I don't know that
it's and it's not everything that's on
the Facebook now Kofi's him it's are you
thinking
you